[Musique]
des enchaînements fabu et danseurs
professionnels
ce samedi ils étaient là pour encadrer
une dizaine de personnes qui
performeront au prisme
je vais préparer les amateurs qui sont
avec moi à une installation qui
s'appelle freestyle ou le but du jeu
c'est de mettre en relation des gens qui
sont dans un espace avec d'autres
personnes qui sont dans un autre espace
via une connexion internet et un ipad
du coup le but c'est de faire danser les
gens dans un endroit à l'autre comme pas
de création particulière pour cette
performance
freestyle se base sur l'improvisation et
sur l'interactivité pas des
professionnels non plus les participants
de cet atelier sont tous amateurs
ça me faisait une occasion de partager
avec le public danse et de préparer
quelque chose là ces professionnels avec
un danseur d'une compagnie
professionnelle et de partager le public
plutôt que de danser dans ma chambre
depuis tout petit je danse en freestyle
autodidacte plutôt hip hop new style
dont deux bouts doit déjà de rencontrer
des gens et aussi le fait bas de pouvoir
se lâcher on connaît pas les gens de
vent qui ont dans ce sens voilà il ya et
puis le fait aussi de pouvoir apprendre
des nouveaux pas parce que moi je
travaillais beaucoup sur la house en
fait est là bas on travaille un peu de
break de repos d'être en contact avec le
public de leur transmettre des
mouvements de leur apprendre des choses
ou que même eux ils peuvent nous
apprendre c'est aussi
bah s'amuser avoir une bonne ambiance
quatre heures de travail qui s'intègre
dans l'exposition danse des guerriers de
la ville un parcours imaginé par la
compagnie par terre à découvrir le 14
janvier prochain